e desde o início da pandemia eu estou em
pânico com as notícias do brasil e do
mundo sem conseguir dormir e chorando
sem parar
o meu maior medo tem sido
e o que vai acontecer com os meus amigos
nonagenários como eles irão sobreviver
física e emocionalmente
e no dia quinze de março às 6:00 da
tarde como acontece todos os dias
o meu melhor amigo josé guedes de 97
anos me ligou
é só que dessa vez ele não estava alegre
animado como sempre
e ele me disse desesperado
oi miriam eu só vejo o caixão na itália
miriam
e os filhos não estão podemos se
despedir dos pais
e tu vai esperar aqui no brasil
e eu fiquei tão angustiada eu respondi
guedes para de ver televisão guedes você
não vai poder fazer nada por quem tá
morrendo natália não vai poder fazer
nada por quem tá morrendo no brasil mas
você pode fazer muito por mim você pode
cuidar de mim eu não vou conseguir
sobreviver se você não cuidar de mim
e na mesma hora ele mudou de atitude e
disse deixa comigo
oi e para minha surpresa receptor de
memória três versos de os lusíadas de
camões
o que deu a sua risada gostosa que enche
o meu coração de alegria
e foi neste exato momento que a minha
vida mudou completamente
e eu descobri que a única saída para ter
um mínimo de equilíbrio e de saúde
mental seria dedicar todo meu tempo
energia e criatividade para cuidar das
pessoas que eu mais amo
e desde então o que é desligar todos os
dias para fazer um joguinho de palavras
que eu inventei para jogar com ele
e depois ele me recita os versos de os
lusíadas é
e no dia quinze de maio
bom dia do seu aniversário de 97 anos eu
cantei para ele
o amigo é coisa para se guardar do lado
esquerdo do peito mesmo que eu tenho
para descansar
e eu disse
oi gente se você é o meu melhor e mais
querido amigo eu amo muito você você é
muito importante para mim e ele disse
emocionado com a voz embargada
é eu sei disso
e quando ele diz seus se diz eu senti um
amor tão profundo que eu percebi que
minha vida pode ter algum significado
nesse momento tão dramático
e também todos os dias a minha doce e
querida amiga thaís de 95 anos me liga
ela foi a minha melhor aluna na casa do
saber fazemos o joguinho de palavras ela
me conta o almoço o teu filho preparou
especialmente para ela e outras
histórias deliciosas sobre seus nove
filhos 18 netos e seis bisnetos snaps
e no final l um dos pensamentos que
anotou no seu caderninho
e o dia ontem foi de clarice lispector
e não se preocupe em entender
a viver ultrapassa todo entendimento
[Música]
mergulhe no que você não conhece
e aí
e a nalva de 92 anos me liga lá de natal
para tocar no piano as músicas que eu
mais gosto valsas boleros tangos
chorinhos bossa-nova ela toca todas sem
partitura
e o verbo que eu mais conjugo com os
meus amigos é compartilhar
e na cantamos juntas e citamos poesias
lemos livros ouvimos música jogamos
caça-palavras conversamos sobre o nosso
dia e principalmente damos muitas e mais
muitas risadas gostosas
e diz massa de 2015 eu só convivo com os
meus amigos não na genarios
a todos muito alegres saudáveis e cheios
de projetos de vida hoje já são mais de
e eles me apelidaram de escutadora dos
velhinhos porque eu amo ouvir suas
histórias de vida
e com eles eu aprendi que o meu tempo é
o meu bem mais precioso que eu preciso
saborear um dia de cada vez e tem
gratidão muita gratidão por estar viva
com saúde e com os meus amigos
e eles me ensinaram que a melhor rima
para felicidade amizade
e por isso eu passei a dizer que eu
tenho 93 anos
e eu me tornei nativa como diz os
antropólogos
quem sabe aquela musiquinha não confie
em ninguém com mais de 30 anos
e eu gosto de cantar não confio em
ninguém com menos de 90 anos
eu nunca eu senti recebi tanto amor em
toda minha vida
e eu sinto uma profunda gratidão por ter
amigos que me dão alegria força e
coragem para levantar da cama todos os
dias
e eles estão me curando do pânico
e do desespero e da depressão
a ter um projeto de vida tem sido
fundamental para minha sobrevivência
física e emocional eu aprendi que apesar
da situação assustadora eu tenho a
liberdade de escolher atitude que possa
ter frente ao sofrimento inevitável eu
estou conseguindo ocupar o meu tempo de
forma útil e produtivo e significativa
escutando conversando amando e cuidando
dos meus amigos
as imagens do que nunca
tá combatendo a velho fobia no brasil
e a pandemia revelou a face mais
perversa de alguns políticos empresários
e autoridades é o que eu chamo de velho
fobia
nós estamos assistindo horrorizados
discursos recheados vestir e vai se
preconceitos e violências contra os mais
velhos como esses
os professores vamos todos nos
contaminar para criar imunidade e essa
epidemia acaba logo só vou morrer os
velhinhos mesmo não vamos parar economia
por causa da vida de alguns velhinhos
eles iriam morrer mais cedo ou mais
tarde
e esse tipo de discurso revela uma
situação que já existia antes da
pandemia
e os mais velhos são considerados
inúteis descartáveis invisíveis homens e
mulheres de mais idade que já viviam uma
espécie de morte simbólica estão
desesperados ao constatar que são
considerados um peso para a sociedade
olá você sabia que a maior parte da
violência contra os velhos ocorre dentro
de casa que que os principais agressores
são os filhos e os netos
a violência física verbal psicológica
abuso financeiro maus-tratos negligência
xingamentos fazem parte da vida dos
velhos bem antes da pandemia
não existe um cruel feminicídio e
infanticídio dentro das casas
é mas não estão correndo também uns
verdadeiros velhos vídeo
há muitos dos que determinam discurso de
ódio e de extermínio dos mais velhos já
passaram dos 60 anos
e aí gente que eles aprendam uma lição
importante
é a única categoria social que todo
mundo é é velho
e a criança e o jovem de hoje são os
velhos de amanhã
e esses velho fóbicos estão construindo
o seu próprio destino como velhos e
também o destino dos seus filhos e dos
seus netos que vocês vêm de amanhã
e a forte reação dos brasileiros contra
esse sociopata genocidas prova que os
mais velhos são muito mas muito
importante para todos nós faremos tudo o
que for necessário para demonstrar que
os nossos velhos não são peso muito pelo
contrário eles é que estão nos ajudando
a sobreviver a encontrar força e coragem
para viver física e mentalmente um
mínimo de equilíbrio
bom então é isso que estão nos ensinando
a ser pessoas muito mais amorosas e
generosa
e são eles que estão cuidando de nós
como cuidarão durante toda a vida
nós somos nós os principais interessados
e uma transformação radical dessa
realidade cruel seja qual for a nossa
idade cronológica
a cada um de nós mesmos mais jovens têm
que se reconhecer no velho que é hoje ou
no velho para tirar amanhã velho não é
um outro velho sou eu
e eu termino então uma pergunta para
todos vocês
e os velhos de hoje e os velhos amanhã
e o que você está fazendo para combater
a vê-lo fobia
se você está escutando amando e cuidando
dos seus velhos
oi oi
e aí
a pregar ainda tá muito parabéns tchau
beijão brilhosa linda maravilhosa
incrível e
[Aplausos]
e aí